modest protests in belarus ahead of
another big rally planned for sunday
a test of will as the regime again ramps
up pressure on rebels
but the opposition leader says the
momentum for change is unstoppable
regardless of crowd size even if we
there this movement will
slow down or come down a little bit but
our people
they will not accept our president
anymore we have changed
how worried are you that tomorrow we'll
see new violence
it's my opinion just um to my opinion uh
our authorities saw that they valid the
violence
they had during those two days
didn't calm down people it just made
them
angry and they understood that they
made a great mistake and
i'm sure that they will not do this
mistake anymore
she fled to lithuania after running
against president alexander lukashenko
in disputed elections
svetlana tikonovskaya says she'll return
home
when the regime is ready for dialogue
and has released political prisoners
including her husband
if maybe even lukashenko says that he
will have dialogue
are you ready and would you be willing
to meet with lukashenko and have
dialogue
directly with him if it is the necessity
of it and i
will understand that it's necessary so
why not
and how long do you think it's going to
take until
you succeed in this mission everybody
has to understood
as to understand that it can last
as couple of days a week so it can take
a lot of
time but i believe in
the fact that our authority
want the best for their countries and
they understand that
this crisis it has to
end and the sooner it ends the better
for country
it's a belief shared by many but the
threat
of arrest state violence and job loss is
real
after two weeks like nothing really
changed you know except for the protests
and i can see that um the active
protests are becoming like a passive
creeping resistance
and of course something like that uh
doesn't make you feel too optimistic
so right now i'm just concerned and i
keep asking myself what's next what's
next
it's a question many will be asking as
they call for change
and as their president refuses to go
debra haines skynys vilnius